il s'est dit beaucoup de choses pendant
la campagne électorale
mais quelle place à occuper la culture
elle est partie en sortie des
plateformes à la dernière minute mais
c'est vraiment axé sur l'économie
l'économie le mont musique le pas
entendu beaucoup le mot culture pour
beaucoup non plus mais mon musée je
désirais encore moins l'enjeu a été à
peine abordée pendant pendant la
campagne du bout des lèvres par quelques
quelques politiciens
ottawa la coalition canadienne des arts
s'est donné le mandat de ramener la
culture au premier plan en envoyant un
questionnaire partis politiques
tous ont répondu sauf le parti
conservateur des réponses sont arrivés
très rapidement et au niveau des
contenus les réponses col de très près à
ce qui avait été demandé par le secteur
depuis plusieurs années on voit d'abord
qu'il ya un consensus au sein de
plusieurs partis par rapport à radio
canada la nécessité de réinvestir dans
radio canada ensuite les parties
s'entendent sur des besoins qui a au
niveau du conseil des arts du canada sur
le besoin d'aller promouvoir nos
artistes à l'étranger
la coalition des arts est également à
l'origine du mot clic voter art que se
sont appropriés certains organismes
culturels
une campagne qui aurait porté fruit on a
davantage parlé de culture pendant cette
campagne sic en 2011
ça c'est clair ce n'est pas assez selon
lui n'être l'union des écrivaines et
écrivains québécois qui a publié une
lettre ouverte incitant les partis
politiques à parler non seulement de
culture mais de livres en fait il ya
juste le bloc québécois que parler
d'abolir la taxe fédérale sur les livres
mais du livre comme tel on n'en a pas
parlé du tout selon lui n'est que le
prochain gouvernement devra réviser ses
lois sur le droit d'auteur ainsi que sur
la faillite et l'insolvabilité
ce qui permettrait de mieux soutenir les
écrivains en parle pas d'eux des
artistes comme tel saufs
je pense quand on parle de double il
le budget du conseil des arts ça ça
devrait éventuellement toucher les
artistes au niveau de la création ayant
eu un expo au musée des beaux-arts pour
amener les partis politiques fédéraux a
parlé du sous financement des musées
québécois une centrale syndicale a lancé
une campagne de sensibilisation qui met
entre autres en vedette xavier dolan il
peut évidemment et il doit y avoir plus
d'argent
le programme fédéral des deux musées et
moi généreux aujourd'hui qu'il ya vingt
ans ce serait une excellente nouvelle
d'apprendre qu'ils auraient des
réinjection dans le programme d'aidé aux
musées aussi de remettre les budgets
niveau et que les critères soient aussi
un peu plus ouvert au niveau du
programme d'aidé aux musées peut-être un
peu moins orienté sur certains aspects
militaires ou politiques
pendant ce temps des artistes partout au
pays se mobilisent dans le cadre du
mouvement imagine canada
le dvd sera venu radio en passant par
rosetta et liu kang world ses musiciens
milite pour un grand changement au
lendemain du scrutin
ici tanya lapointe radio canada montréal
et